erica is in Salt Lake City Utah hi Erica
how are you hi gave her great thank you
so much for taking my call
sure what's up I have a question about
how much I should share in some medical
bills so my situation is that I am
currently in baby set to working on
paying off some student loans I
originally started at 75,000 and I'm now
down to 48,000 what are you making here
I heard it fifty and with overtime and
that kind of thing I've gotten up to
about 75 good job and you're single yeah
yes okay so your question medical bills
will share in medical bills Sharon whose
medical bills um my sister so why would
you share in her medical bills so um he
um I've had some struggles and he sent
me um um a hospice nurse be anyway so I
she's met me a text and it was very
concerning to me and so I called the
police
and they went and picked her up and she
was hospitalized for over a week she
threatened suicide yes yeah that's what
happens when you get when you threaten
suicide well yeah I and and I'm just
wondering because I need you
involuntarily committed she's very upset
with me right now
well then it is not your fault she
threatened suicide right right you tell
work yeah not yeah you didn't cause us
she caused this you saved her life so so
you don't think that I should know she's
mentally ill okay she's mentally ill so
what she thinks about this is irrelevant
okay um you saved her life didn't you
yeah and I think so I mean I don't I
don't regret calling I okay even if
she's mad at me I don't care she's
managed if she could be mad at me
oh my bother me a bit but listen that's
how it works when you get to spend time
in a psych ward when you threaten
suicide because they call a police in in
every state and by the way that's a good
thing keeps you from limiting suicide
yeah
she's obviously mentally unstable bless
her heart she's got something she's
working through but no you don't pay her
medical bills because she threatened to
commit suicide by the way you're broke I
know well and I wasn't thinking I could
just pay them outright I was wondering
if you thought that I was responsible
for any portion if I should put them in
my snowball if I should only and then my
snowball if I could help her in any way
No so if I'm not hoping if you want to
help her because you'll and because
somebody sends you a check for ten
million dollars and you want to help her
because you love her and you have some
extra money that's fine but are you in
any way morally obligated to pay her
bills no I'll just tell you if you tell
me right now that you're thinking of
suicide the police will be there in a
few minutes and I will pay none of your
medical bills yeah
not one yeah and I won't feel and I
won't lose even one ounce of sleep over
it
because I will consider myself having
done a good deed to save your life you
follow me you did the right thing yeah
do the right thing and it doesn't
morally obligated to pay your bills if
you threaten suicide right now in the
air it's not gonna you know in sand
that's happened here by the way and
we've had that we've had the police show
up over there we've had the they call
customer care here and threatened
suicide and guess what you know Popo
shows up man and takes it our business
because he saves lives and you know
we're not gonna be sitting here liable
because we're sitting in Tennessee and
somebody calls me from somewhere and
threatens that and you did the right
thing so nobody you just love yourself
and you just got to have some boundaries
and you can love her but she's mentally
struggling so what her feelings are
towards you regarding this are not
relevant it hurts but they're not
relevant this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope
you're enjoying the Dave Ramsey show
and did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better than the Dave Ramsey channel
don't tell them I said that I'm kidding
I'm kidding so subscribe and there's
lots of videos about life and money so
while you're at it if you want to check
out a video then you can check out how
to do a monthly budget one of the best
videos out there
you